first we can somebody please remind joe
biden pretty pleased with sugar on top
that our fellow citizens are still
trapped in afghanistan joe has not even
mentioned
these americans not one time in over a
hundred days
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day
116.
day 116 129 days since joe promised he
would not do this
abandoning our fellow american citizens
and turning his back on them and green
card holders and military families and
by the way our afghan allies on top of
it and tonight either joe biden doesn't
care doesn't remember after all well he
has good days and mostly bad days and
unfortunately today was another real
struggle for this declining president
take a look
president i don't think he is where am i
sir i'm right here now he's a county
executive in jackson county
resident in the business
to uh
as well you know i mean this guy's done
it all
look
look
as emmanuel as man said we're we're in a
situation where we've known that our
infrastructure had problems for a long
long time under the leadership of
mayors like uh you know our mayor here
this is the united states of mayor for
god's sake
this is not funny anymore that's the guy
supposedly standing firm against putin
and president xi putin yesterday that's
the guy who is now tasked with keeping
america safe defending our interests
around the world joe biden can barely
complete a coherent sentence his
cognitive state seems to be now
deteriorating daily and here's a
question does anyone in the biden white
house anybody do they care at all
how bad this is for him personally do
they care how bad this is for this
country do they care how dangerous it is
for this country and for the entire
world how long is everyone in the white
house going to pretend
that he's not a cognitive mess which we
all know he is and get this today the
pathetic week joe biden accidentally
actually revealed his strategy to deal
with the hostile actor vladimir putin
and his hostile regime and his hostile
activity and the way is to accommodate
them pretty much kiss their ass in any
way possible
we hope by friday we're going to be able
to stay and announce you who are having
meetings at a higher level not just with
us but with at least four of our major
nato allies and russia to discuss the
future of
russia's concerns relative to nato writ
large
and whether or not we can work out any
accommodations as it relates to bringing
down the temperature along the eastern
front
joe you're the president you're not a
concierge at a five-star hotel you don't
need to accommodate vladimir putin and i
need to say this if you're an american
in ukraine and somehow you hear my voice
get out now if you have loved ones there
my advice is get them the hell out of
there as quickly as possible now given
what happened in afghanistan i have no
faith in neither should anyone else that
joe will prevent chaos in carnage in
eastern europe our enemies our allies
all know that joe biden is in a severe
cognitive decline and is in way over his
head the american people also now know
and realize that joe biden is not fit
for this job according to a poll
published in the boston herald yesterday
only 22 percent of americans now support
any biden reelection and get this kamala
harris she's polling even lower at 12
percent a rasmussen poll shows that half
of all likely voters have a very
unfavorable opinion of kamala meanwhile
the wall street journal poll reveals a
massive 30-point swing among hispanic
american voters who are now evenly split
in a head-to-head rematch between trump
and biden the same poll shows a majority
of voters are pessimistic about biden's
leadership the economy a variety of
other issues in other words biden is one
of the worst performing presidents of
all time and it's getting worse where do
we get friday's numbers where do we get
that cbo scoring that doesn't include
the sunset provisions that democrats
want in other words the fake accounting
where do we get friday's inflation
numbers
i would imagine we stay at a 31-year
high don't worry the administration
knows just how to right the ship they
decided what we really need is a
rebranding campaign and to beg the media
to to sell our build back better
nonsense uh for us and by the way now
big signs with the slogan building a
better america that will follow joe
biden all over the country as he touts
his many great achievements
i can't name one but whatever they are
the big administration laughably
believing their poll numbers are so low
because what the messaging is bad what
they need the madison avenue campaign to
to somehow if they did if they just
message it better messengered it better
they do better these numbers are so low
because their policies are that bad it's
that simple their execution is even
worse their agenda is even more
destructive their great green new deal
socialist marxist ideas are insane and
their leader joe is cognitively
declining by the day and the results are
palpable in 2020 we warned everyone that
joe biden was not competent in any way i
honestly wish we were wrong sadly it
might be even worse than we thought and
his radical staff is now hell-bent on
ramming his socialist agenda if he even
knows what it is the bernie biden
manifesto through congress here's an
idea
let's talk to the republican leader in
the senate mitch mcconnell
he said for months two months that
republicans would not help the democrats
raise the debt ceiling and he did just
that and now he's doing it again
mitch mcconnell needs to stop bailing
the democrats out mitch mcconnell is
breaking his word mitch mcconnell is
lying to every republican and he's
scheming with pelosi and schumer behind
the scenes and he is giving them a
lifeline when they totally completely
have kept republicans
out of the budgetary process he gifted
them with more time to raise the debt
ceiling after two months of saying he
wouldn't giving them a window to pass
build back better socialism he promised
he'd never do it again and guess what
mitch mcconnell well now ready to
capitulate one more time he just needs
nine other senators to help him lindsey
graham tonight was furious take a look
to the leadership of both sides i like
you senator mcconnell has been a great
republican leader minority leader
majority leader but this is a moment
where i want to be on the record to say
i don't like this
what we've done is allow the house of
representative
to change a senate rule
no matter what the subject matter that's
not a good idea
we set in place a process that allows
our democratic colleagues to raise the
debt ceiling without using
reconciliation the budget process hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else